you can't give black people time travel
questions
i would rather be anything other than in
1900
[Music]
i'm brian simpson i'm here to answer the
internet who is the hottest celebrity
you'd have a chance with if they got to
know you
does your cat
hey yeah
yeah i'm gonna shoot my shot one of
these days i'm gonna shoot my shot have
a chance just a chance i didn't i didn't
say a good chance i give myself like
twenty percent
one out of five yeah i'm just saying if
she catch me on one of my back on one of
my good days yeah and i'm sharp and i'm
witty and i'm dressed nice yeah
i'm in there how much money would it
take for you to give up your favorite
food for the rest of your life
who the [ __ ] has a favorite food
yeah it's like it's like a favorite song
it's like depending on what mood i'm in
yeah
but like so so okay i'll just rephrase
it for me all my favorite foods yeah
sure
um it would have to be
in the billions does it bother you if a
girl you're dating makes more money than
you
that's never happened before
only i mean i guess it would only but it
would only bother me if if you know if
she had a little attitude about it like
like if she was trying to boss up on me
because she made them because she made
the money yeah but it wouldn't bother me
emotionally you know it's like dating
somebody that's taller than you it's
like it only bothers me if you like if
you think it's flexing right yeah yeah
so yeah that wouldn't bother me now if
every time you finish sex a song play
what would it what would you want it to
be
um
damn
people in the streets
because i just feel like we both get
into it
eventually nobody can resist that song
are there sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate absolutely not
in parenthesis it says
funerals
tragedies
religious holidays etc nope nope i'll
masturbate it in the church bathroom
[Laughter]
no no there's no sacred day what does
that even mean
i gotta blast off yeah no fasting over
here
would you take a million dollars to be
one of the pick the picket people for
the westboro baptist church during a
fallen soldier's funeral of course
[Laughter]
what are we talking about here
it's a million dollars i was unsure i
was like man this hits on like so many
levels that are in black and high notes
no but but
no one's being harmed i'm just getting a
million dollars
but let's say let's say you're like uh
on the news or something and you're like
behind the guy and it's like oh [ __ ]
he's in the worst part and then when
people ask me about i'll be like give me
a million dollars
[Laughter]
now i'm a bitcoin billionaire
would you rather get pegged by a randy
johnson fastball in the ring wow that
question really changed
by randy johnson that still doesn't
clear up where they're going here
would you rather get hit
by a randy johnson fastball in the ribs
hit by a ray lewis coming across the
middle
or punched in the face by floyd
mayweather
i'm gonna take the punch from floyd
mayweather
yeah that's
come on and i'm not saying floyd can't
not floyd can't knock me out
but but the thing is when you get
knocked out you don't feel it
it's just yeah you just wake up right
you know what i mean
it's like it's like time traveling or
whatever um would you [ __ ] a porn star
if afterward she had to hold a press
conference on your performance no no no
absolutely not my evil is so fragile
yeah and porn stars have you ever seen
porn like it's not it's not worth it
it's not worth it just because their
pawn style don't mean that
you're gonna have you're gonna have a
good time
well
if they give you the treatment
if they give you the treatment yeah and
they're giving you their best i feel
like you're gonna have a good time
um
yeah
experience yeah
[Laughter]
what do you think is the oldest
someone's been when they've had sex
like in the history of time and do you
think like uh oh i think there's people
that have died never having done it
never for sure yeah yeah but what so
like do you think there's been someone
who's like a hundred years old that's
had sex
oh for the first time yeah no no no just
like could just be the last time oh oh
those someone's been when they've had
sex um yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna say
i'mma say probably
88 but i do i do know old people be old
people
everything hurts no one cares if i get a
bump would you rather be filthy rich in
1900
or poor now
you can't give black people time travel
questions
i would rather be anything other than in
1900
what's a rich black man in 1900 that's
that's just like being poor that's not
that's not useful at all would you
rather your girlfriend be able to read
your thoughts during sex
or all the time except during sex
jesus christ
[ __ ]
during sex yeah yeah
all the time yeah
that that that's gonna get you in
trouble yeah
would you rather spend the rest of your
life in a country music video or rap
music video
country i do country yeah
i feel like i would just
it would be too many lights flashing and
yeah because the other thing is i'm
thinking the rest of my life and i'm
thinking so like i'm 90.
and you're still and i'm [ __ ]
right i would just be over yeah i'd be
over the party yeah how long could you
last on the run after robbing the bank
oh i'll be i'll get away with it forever
yeah
yeah
yeah that makes you feel like you use
your credit card they know it you know
what i mean like they know where you are
you got to have like all your money set
you got to have a place to go yeah i
would i would i'd
because i there's no way i would rob a
bank
until i unless i planned out every
[ __ ] detail like five years of
planning carefully selecting the team
you know and we wouldn't use no real
names masks and all that yeah everybody
yeah bass nobody wouldn't know who each
other was no loose cannons
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah there's no ain't
gonna be no people we ain't sure about
we got the facial recognition
they got [ __ ] and in the
internet i mean you've seen what
happened when the internet tried to
solve a crime
come on man there's no way you could get
away with it now i mean there's people
still doing it right yeah but you got to
go rob a bank that's like in the middle
of nowhere that don't have wi-fi they
don't got wi-fi you probably got a
chance if you had to watch one category
of porn for the rest of your life what
would it be
oh man
that's easy
it would be
here we go it would be surpr surprise
cream pies
because i love i i i love the oh no you
came into me i love that i don't know
why i think because that was my first
experience
it was like it was like oh no what did
you do that's my favorite and there's no
it doesn't matter what like the the
pretense is doesn't matter it's like
it was like you know girlfriend or
stepmom or anything i don't care about
that but as long as it's like why did
you come into me
especially after she's like come inside
me and then he does it and she's like
why did you do that
i love that i love that it's like this
is wrong
and now it's more wrong if there was a
snail following you
for the rest of your life
and if you touched it you die
how long could you survive right and and
and
it's it's immortal
it goes okay because i'm not trying i'm
not trying to hypothetical my way out of
the hypothetical yeah you know what i'm
saying so
he'll never stop he can cross oceans he
can fly i'll survive till the day i die
you think so i was i would die like if
this was the only thing that could kill
me i would die of natural causes
there's no [ __ ] way to spill is going
to catch you i feel like
you just never know though you lay down
at night you're like the snail is not
like well you look you just look you
just you just gotta be on you just gotta
be on your [ __ ] purpose you
know what i'm saying you gotta get up
every day and run a mile
that gives you at least 48 hours
[Laughter]
you know just got to keep going yeah i
mean you move everything you know it's
like yeah you got to keep going you got
to be constantly aware of where this
[ __ ] is yeah do you think okay
how about this do you think that that
snail takes credit when you die at 60 of
stress he's like i got it yeah i mean
i'm getting a heart attack
nervous
my pro my problem would be you know one
day i'm like severely depressed and i
turn around and just start running back
towards the snail
just [ __ ] it
[Laughter]
thank you for watching answer the
internet with brian simpson please like
subscribe for future episodes and
comment i don't know where to look on
this thing i'm bad with the iphones but
comment what other comics you'd like to
see play ati